son apuestos ricos y famosos y eso
parece encantar al mundo los
espectadores fascinados siguen el juicio
transmitido por televisión y por
plataformas como youtube en el que depp
acusa a su ex esposa de de información
por un artículo publicado en the
washington post en 2018 en el que
aseguraba haber sufrido abuso doméstico
todo lo que se dice se ha convertido en
una avalancha de contenidos en redes
sociales que las redes sociales como
todos los mensajes de los medios de
comunicación son recortes de lo que
ocurre lo estamos viviendo como una
especie de serie de netflix como una
especie de película en etapas este ha
sido tan mediatizado que un canal como
el down crime que hace una transmisión
en vivo tiene al menos nueve millones de
espectadores conectados todos los días o
corte tv que ha cuadruplicado su
audiencia según asegura el diario
'independent' hay un interés y una
relevancia pero el peligro el peligro de
este interés en la trivialización y la
banalización por eso vemos
inmediatamente después de cada
testimonio clips vídeos twitter se llena
de tendencias sobre el juicio algunas de
carácter violento tick tock se desborda
de toda clase de vídeos se analiza
expone e incluso ridiculizar a ambos
actores la cantidad de información que
tenemos información descontextualizada
información fragmentaria lo que va
haciendo es generando una tendencia
respecto de la creación de opiniones
incluso para quienes están viendo el
juicio los vídeos de recortes sobre el
mismo juicio
construyen una forma de leer lo que pasa
distinta como una película con un guión
truncado el rol que no les fue asignado
a hard and deep seguir acondicionando su
popularidad